it might be the middle of January but
there were still a few Game of the Year
awards to hand out from last year the
academy of interactive arts and sciences
has revealed its nominees for the best
games of 2015 rise the tomb raider and
the witcher 3 wild hunt are at the top
of the pile with eight nominations each
tomb raider and witcher 3 are nominated
for overall game of the year of course
but blood-borne fallout 4 and ori and
the blind forest are also up for the big
prize plenty of other games have
received multiple nominations too
including star wars battlefront and
batman arkham knight we have the full
list of nominees at gamespot the dice
awards will be held in las vegas on
thursday febuary 18th with returning
host Pete Holmes Metal Gear creator
Hideo Kojima will be inducted into the
Hall of Fame and former nintendo
president satoru Otto will be honored
with a posthumous Lifetime Achievement
Award 2016 is shaping up to be a big
year for gaming it's always nice to look
back you can still check out our game of
the year coverage at gamespot.com / game
of the year and for all the video game
news you need in the new year you'll
already be in the right place